I heard a tip that when you are ready to
wrap it up that you have something you
do what is it okay so when I was on The
Today Show because it's very very finely
time oh and that is live and that is a
whole different thing they will cut you
off the computer will cut you off so I
said to this person I was interviewing I
said because they were not a
professional there was somebody who was
just an amateur who doesn't go on TV a
lot right when it's time for us to wrap
up I'll just I'll just briefly you know
I'll just tap you with my foot and that
means comfortably finish what you're
saying so I get the the sign from the
person behind the camera I go like that
nothing happens I hit a little bit
harder I'm not gonna hit you as hard as
I hit this person I'm basically beating
the pie out of this guy
finally I have to cut him off he had a
prosthesis
[Applause]
well Dad tap their legs
I was so embarrassed